Identify the most
reasonable units
to measure the weight
of the choices below.
So we have an average
adult, a slice of bread,
a kitchen table,
or a pack of gum.
So I am an average
adult, and I know
that I weigh about 160 pounds.
So I know that pounds are
a pretty good measurement
for about something
the weight of an adult.
So I'll put adults in that
category right over there.
Now we have a single
slice of bread.
So even a full loaf of
bread doesn't weigh a lot.
Maybe that gets close to a
pound, but a slice of bread
is going to be
less than a pound.
So I would do this in ounces.
A kitchen table.
Well, a kitchen table
kind of weighs the same--
it could, if it's a very
large kitchen table,
could weigh the same
or more than an adult.
So I would do this in pounds.
And then a pack of gum.
So once again, a pack
of gum is fairly light.
If you've ever been
to the gym and held
even a 1-pound or
2-pound weight,
it weighs more
than a pack of gum.
So a pack of gum is going
to be less than a pound,
so ounces seem to
make sense here.